madame le pen monsieur macron bonsoir
c'est la préoccupation qui est revenu le
plus dans l'esprit des français faut-il
oui ou non verser le lait avant les
serial bien sûr que oui parce que sinon
je me présenterai pas
pour être président de la république
c'est une immense ferme nous avons
incontestablement ils divergent nous
avons très clairement une divergence et
je pense que ce que vous proposez
est une trahison ce qu'est l'esprit
français et la république
véloce comment faites-vous pour est que
plus beau
non ma tantie caméras
il y en a trois qui dit ça comment
faites-vous pour entretenir at elle
soigne
une routine de beauté non
j'ai mangé des pâtes bon du coup on en
dit quoi
macro 1 ce que vous avez dit vous êtes
en direct la baie du con agua macro
c'est l'homme qui fait rêver ni les
mains strubbe et femmes ça faisait deux
mois je n'ai pas eu mais mince mais dès
que j'ai entendu la victoire de mâcon
bouffe et c'est venu
mathieu
faut
le jeu c'est pourquoi on ne trouve pas
de corbeil à côté des piscines
la corbeille à papier
c'est ce qui dit en bout à sa femme le
jour de l'an
je te souhaite une bonne année
[Musique]